This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇妙的现代世界中，我将剖析精神韧性、体能以及构建心理弹性的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。搜索数字2%，即可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我也非常重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。这向世界发出了信号：你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian,
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋，
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。请收听《Love Trapped》播客
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。我发誓。
will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I'm going to give a little heads up to you guys today. I'm quite ill. If you're watching on Netflix, you'll see I have
将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逍遥法外的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十多岁的心理学。今天我要先给大家提个醒。我病得挺重的。如果你在Netflix上观看，你会看到我
this cup of tea in front of me. And there's a little secret to this cup of tea. There's actually three tea bags in it. I mixed two lemon and ginger and then one throat sooth. So I've invented an entire new tea flavour and I also don't have any taste buds right now. So it's honestly doing the trick. But throughout this episode, I'm sure you're going to hear some horrible nasal noises. And I'm so sorry and I wish I could fix it. But the show must go on, especially because there was no way I was missing. There we go. We just got some. There's no way I was missing. seeing today's episode because it is a long-awaited episode, probably one of my most personally researched. We're talking about the psychology of personal style. I have been so
面前有这杯茶。这杯茶里其实有个小秘密。里面其实放了三个茶包。我混合了两个柠檬生姜茶和一个喉部舒缓茶。所以我发明了一种全新口味的茶，而且我现在的味蕾完全失灵了。所以老实说，这确实起到了作用。但在这一集里，我确信你们会听到一些可怕的鼻音。我真的很抱歉，我希望我能解决这个问题。但节目必须继续，特别是绝无可能缺席。好了，我们刚收到一些。绝无可能缺席。观看今天的节目，因为这是一集期待已久的节目，可能也是我个人做过最多研究的节目之一。我们正在讨论个人风格的心理学。我最近一直
drawn into the psychology of fashion recently. I'm not a particularly fashionable person. I don't really think about it that often, but like just the psychology behind why we wear what we wear, why we choose certain colors, why we are drawn to certain accessories, even certain animal prints, like there is a massive rabbit hole that you can fall into looking into this. And I want to share some of my findings. The thing is, what we choose to wear isn't, it's not the most important thing about us. And I'm sure there are some people who would disagree with me. There are some diehard, like, fashion fans out there who would say it's the most important thing in the world. But, you know, there's definitely plenty of more that matters what you do with your time, your values,
被时尚心理学深深吸引。我并不是一个特别时尚的人。我其实并不经常去想它，但是就像我们穿什么衣服背后的心理学、为什么我们选择特定的颜色、为什么我们被某些配饰所吸引，甚至是某些动物纹，就像研究这些时，你会陷入一个巨大的兔子洞。我想分享我的一些发现。问题是，我们选择穿什么并不是，并不是关于我们最重要的事情。我确信有些人会不同意我的看法。有一些狂热的，像时尚迷这样的人会说这是世界上最重要的事情。但是，你知道的，还有很多更重要的事情，比如你如何利用时间、你的价值观、
your hobbies, et cetera, et cetera. But when you think about it, it getting dressed is incredibly psychologically revealing because it is a ritual it is a thing that we do every single day and what we choose to get dressed in every single day that decision can reveal some really significant things about our personality about our insecurities how we were in childhood it's honestly so mind-blowing what we're going to get into today whether you care about fashion a lot. You have a Vogue subscription, whether you care about it a medium amount or not at all. I really don't care because you're going to hear a fact today that is going to blow your mind. I promise you that. And you may also learn how to make better style choices based on your identity and your
你的爱好等等，等等。但仔细想想，穿衣打扮在心理学上具有极强的启发性，因为它是一种仪式，是我们每天都在做的事情，而我们每天选择穿什么衣服，这个决定可以揭示出关于我们性格、我们的不安全感、我们在童年中是如何度过的一些非常显著的事情，今天我们要深入探讨的内容简直令人大开眼界，无论你是否非常关心时尚。你是否订阅了《Vogue》，无论你对时尚的关注度是一般还是完全不关心。我真的不在乎，因为你今天会听到一个让你大开眼界的真相。我向你保证。你可能还会学到如何根据你的身份认同和个性来做出更好的风格选择。
personality. And you may also save yourself some money and some time by being able to curate a wardrobe based on what you're going to find out about yourself today. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of personal style. I think the magical thing about fashion and personal style is that clothing is obviously one of the most immediate and obvious forms of self-expression that we can have. And that is what makes it so mentally significant because it's basically, looking at what somebody wears every day can help us decipher so much about how they want us to see them. Your clothes, aren't just pieces of fabric. They are a first impression. They are a profession for some people.
而且，通过能够根据你今天将要了解到的关于你自己的信息来精心挑选衣橱，你可能还能为自己省下一些钱和时间。所以废话不多说，让我们进入个人风格心理学吧。我认为时尚和个人风格神奇的地方在于，服装显然是我们所能拥有的最直接、最明显的自我表达形式之一。这就是为什么它在心理上如此重要，因为基本上，观察一个人每天穿什么可以帮助我们解读出他们希望我们如何看待他们的许多信息。你的衣服不只是一块块布料。它们是第一印象。对于某些人来说，它们是一种职业。
They are an identity hallmark. And they cause a reaction in other people. A 23 Canadian study found that. People immediately make some pretty rapid and pretty on the nose conclusions about everything from our cognitive state to our social status to our aesthetic status within seconds of seeing what we're wearing. And they're very accurate assessments. And as, people, we know that. We know that whether we like it or not, people are making broader assessments about us based on our clothes. It's why we agonise over a first date dress or we agonise over what to wear to a job interview or what colour of jeans is best when they all kind of look the same. Those reactions we get to our clothes are part of what actually informs our personal
它们是身份的标志。并且它们会在其他人身上引发反应。一项2023年的加拿大研究发现。人们在看到我们穿着的几秒钟内，就会立即对我们的认知状态、社会地位以及审美状态等各个方面做出相当迅速且相当中肯的结论。而且这些评估非常准确。而且作为人类，我们知道这一点。无论我们愿意与否，我们都知道人们正在根据我们的衣服对我们做出更广泛的评估。这就是为什么我们为第一次约会的连衣裙纠结不已，或者为面试穿什么而苦恼，或者当它们看起来都差不多时，到底什么颜色的牛仔裤最好。我们对衣服的这种反应，实际上是从非常非常小的年龄就开始塑造我们个人风格的部分原因。
style from a very, very young age. I think we take personal style for granted sometimes. and we think that it's just kind of like appeared or it's just based on trends. But from very early on, we are actually conditioned to choose the kinds of clothes that we continue to wear for the rest of our lives. And I think that is something not many of us know. Our childhood is a huge fundamental part of our fashion choices. And this is because of a very fundamental psychological process called associative learning. Essentially, at some stage, your brain begins to live. link clothing choices with certain feelings and certain outcomes that were either good, bad,
我想有时候我们把个人风格视为理所当然。并且我们认为它只是某种凭空出现的东西，或者只是基于潮流。但从很小的时候起，我们实际上就被潜移默化地去选择那些我们将伴随一生并继续穿着的服装类型。我想这是我们很多人都不知道的事情。我们的童年是我们的时尚选择中一个极其基础的重要部分。这是因为一个非常基础的心理学过程，叫做联想学习。本质上，在某个阶段，你的大脑开始将。服装选择与某些感觉和某些结果联系起来，这些结果无论是好、坏、
neutral, exciting, terrible, or something else. So this starts actually fairly randomly. Most associative learning does, but obviously when we're young, when we're kids, like, we don't pick our clothes. Our parents pick our clothes for us. And their style is essentially our style. My mom was born in Wisconsin. My dad was born in Queensland. And so when I was a kid, I was always dressed in like a mix of Oshkosh-Bogosh overalls, if you know what those are, and like beachwear and t-shirts. You know, you don't really have a choice. But what you do start to realize and notice is when certain items get a positive reaction
中性、兴奋、糟糕还是其他什么。所以这其实是从相当随机的事情开始的。大多数联想学习都是如此，但很明显，当我们还小的时候，当我们是孩子的时候，我们并不自己挑选衣服。我们的父母为我们挑选衣服。他们的风格本质上就是我们的风格。我妈妈出生在威斯康星州。我爸爸出生在昆士兰州。所以当我还是个孩子的时候，我总是穿着那种奥什科什·博戈什（OshKosh B'gosh）背带裤的混搭——如果你知道那是什么的话——还有海滩装和T恤。你知道的，你其实没有选择的余地。但你确实开始意识到并注意到的是，什么时候某些单品会得到积极的反应，
and when certain items don't, or how certain items make you feel. What made you feel comfortable? What made you feel safe? What made you feel close to your parents? What made you fit in? I remember there was a certain long dress. used to wear that my grandma bought me. And the first time I wore it, like, everybody in my family made such a huge fuss about how nice I looked in it. And I would wear it all the time. I would
什么时候不会，或者某些单品会让你有什么感觉。什么让你感到舒适？什么让你感到安全？什么让你觉得离父母更近？什么让你融入其中？我记得有一件特定的长裙。我以前常穿，是我奶奶给我买的。我第一次穿它的时候，我家里所有人都为我穿上它有多好看而大惊小怪。我后来就一直穿它。我甚至会
literally twirl in it. I would go up to strangers to show them my great dress and they'd be like, where the hell is this child's parents? But that was such a learned association. And it was so funny. Last week, I was looking for an outfit for a friend's wedding. And I found a dress that looks really similar and it was like this gravitational pull like this is something that I know this is something that like I have this long ago positive association with and I ended up buying the dress for that reason alone. I also remember feeling the most myself in like my buzz light your shirt. I knew that was comfortable. I knew I could move around. I knew I could be a child in that. That was my my safety blanket. So that's how you learn. But on the other side, you also learn yes through positive things,
穿着它转圈。我会走到陌生人面前向他们展示我的漂亮裙子，他们会想：这个小孩的父母到底在哪儿？但这是一种深刻习得的联想。而且这太有趣了。上周，我在为朋友的婚礼寻找一套衣服。我找到了一条看起来非常相似的裙子，它就像有一种万有引力一样，这让我觉得这是我熟悉的东西，这是我很久以前就对其产生积极联想的东西，我最终仅仅因为这个原因买下了这条裙子。我还记得穿着巴斯光年T恤时最像我自己。我知道那是舒服的。我知道我可以活动。我知道我可以在其中做一个孩子。那是我的，我的安全毯。这就是你的学习方式。但在另一方面，你也学会了，是的，通过积极的事情，
also through negative things. You learn what gets you teased, what elicits negative reactions. Maybe it was wearing a crop top in your childhood and you were teased for it, you were ashamed for it. Some kids said terrible things for you and so you grow up thinking you can't wear that and you never do or you wear a type of pet or a type of gene that ripped or gave you a rash and for some reason you've avoided that for the rest of your life. Clothes carry learnt associations. That is why certain clothes, like we were talking about, feel emotionally relevant because they are often tied to memories, the same memories that our identity is built on. In fact, researchers from the University of College London looked at this in great detail. And they basically said in this article they wrote, and I can't remember the name of it, but they said that clothes are instruments for anchoring the self.
也通过消极的事情。你懂得了什么会招致嘲笑，什么会引发负面反应。也许这源于你在童年时期穿了一件露脐上衣，为此你受到了嘲笑和羞辱。有些孩子对你说了一些可怕的话，于是你长大后认为自己不能穿那样的衣服，并且再也没有穿过；或者你穿了一种容易裂开或让你起红疹的裤子或牛仔裤，出于某种原因，你在余生中都避开了它们。衣服承载着习得的联想。这就是为什么某些衣服，就像我们刚才谈到的那样，在情感上具有相关性，因为它们通常与记忆联系在一起，也就是我们构建自我身份所依凭的同一批记忆。事实上，伦敦大学学院的研究人员对此进行了非常详细的研究。他们基本上在他们写的一篇文章中指出——我不记得文章的名字了——但他们说衣服是锚定自我的工具，
and remembering the past and through that they enhance our well-being. They are like this weird rope that ties together who we want to be, who we are now, and who we were in the past in like one long line. Clothes are a mix of, yes, practicality and what's affordable, but also of mood and memory, and that is constantly playing subconsciously in the background of the choices you make around fashion every single day. It's incredibly emotionally evocative. It's incredibly representative of the past. It's why I think we struggle to throw out items that we don't wear anymore, but used to be our favorites.
并借此回忆过去，从而提升我们的幸福感。它们就像一根神奇的绳索，把我们想成为的人、现在的我和过去的我串联成一条长长的线。服装是实用性、经济性与情绪、记忆的结合，并且这种结合在日常生活中不断潜意识地在你的时尚选择背景下发挥着作用。它在情感上极为动人。它极具过去的代表性。这就是为什么我认为我们很难扔掉那些不再穿了、但曾经是我们的最爱的物品。
It's why we have really distinct childhood memories, not just of moments, but of the clothes that we wore in them. They are not neutral items. Beyond these past memories, research also shows that your baseline personality can also predict how you will dress, essentially there is this kind of theory that if you were to take somebody's outfit, you could pick it apart and basically make a composite of what their personality is like based on some some pretty amazing correlations between personality attributes and clothing choices. We can specifically look at this through the big five personality domains or personality the principles. So just as a little refresh, the biggest theory on personality is that our
这就是为什么我们会有如此清晰的童年记忆，不仅是对某些时刻的记忆，还包括我们在那些时刻穿的衣服。它们绝非中性物品。除了这些过去的记忆，研究还表明，你的基本性格也可以预测你的着装方式，本质上存在这样一种理论：如果你拿走某人的衣服，你可以把它拆解开，并根据性格特征和服装选择之间一些非常惊人的相关性，基本拼凑出他们性格的综合画像。我们可以具体通过大五人格领域或性格原则来了解这一点。所以作为简单的复习，关于性格的最主要理论是，我们的
personality is made of five traits. Those are extroversion, openness to experience, neuroticism, agreeableness, and conscientiousness. And if we look at the profile of each of these, where you sit on those ladder, where you sit on that spectrum for each of those traits is going to essentially reveal your clothing choices. So starting with openness to experience, people high, this trait often value play and they value aesthetics and they are creative and they are curious and inquisitive and unconventional. Because of that, according to a paper published in the Polish Psychological Forum in 2024, if you are high in that, you are more likely to seek original items of clothing. You are typically more fashionable as they called it. You are most
性格由五个特质组成。它们是外向性、开放性、神经质、宜人性和责任心。如果我们观察这其中每一个特质的轮廓，你在每一个特质的阶梯上、在那个光谱上所处的位置，基本上就会揭示出你的服装选择。从开放性开始，在这个特质上得分高的人通常重视游戏和美学，他们富有创造力、好奇心、求知欲且不拘一格。正因为如此，根据2024年发表在《波兰心理学论坛》上的一篇论文，如果你在这个特质上得分很高，你更有可能寻求原创的服装单品。正如他们所说，你通常更具时尚感。由于你的这种求知欲和那种实验性的个性，你极有可能是
likely to be somebody who adopts the new trend first because of that intellectual curiosity and that kind of experimental personality that you have. People in contrast who are low in openness to experience, there's actually been all this research that they wear more subdubed clothes. They're more likely to want a capsule wardrobe. They're more likely to gravitate towards the same shapes, colors, like, yeah, silhouettes or features of clothing that they have for a very long time. So, openness to experience is this first thing that we can kind of divide fashion profiles by. Are you more colourful, creative, experimental, or are you more, do you kind of more dress? I don't want to say subdued because that's kind of, I think that has negative connotations,
最先接受新潮流的人。相反，在开放性上得分较低的人，实际上有所有的研究表明他们会穿着更低调的衣服。他们更有可能想要一个胶囊衣橱。他们更有可能倾向于他们长期以来一直穿着的相同的版型、颜色，比如，是的，剪影或服装特征。所以，开放性是我们按其划分时尚画像的第一件事。你是更色彩斑斓、富有创造力、充满实验精神，还是更倾向于，我不想说低调，因为我觉得那有点负面色彩，
but in a more subtle way, in a more ordered way. Next up are the extroverts. According to a 2021 Frontiers in Psychology study, extroverts do in fact dress differently from the rest of us. For this group, clothing is a significant social signal. The study looked at almost 800 women and found that extroverts preferred clothing that are seen as dramatic. They are more likely to combine styles and combine color palettes.
但以一种更微妙、更有秩序的方式？接下来是外向者。根据2021年《心理学前沿》的一项研究，外向者确实与我们其他人穿得不同。对于这个群体来说，服装是一个重要的社交信号。该研究调查了近800名女性，发现外向者更喜欢被视为戏剧化的服装。他们更有可能将不同的风格和调色板结合起来。
They are less likely to choose clothes that camouflage them. And that really makes a lot of sense. I feel like extroverts are the ones like holding up the fun jewelry Etsy shops. and like the worded t-shirt stores because they're looking for a way to display their personality as vividly as possible to kind of almost like a butterfly like attract people in. Let's go in the opposite direction. If extroverts lean more that way, what is the say about people whose clothes are always professional and pressed and very neat and tidy? These people are like the hallmarks of conscientiousness. According to that same 2021 study, these individuals, although they are very socially aware, although they are confident, they seem to gravitate more towards classic formal styles.
他们不太可能选择那些能将自己伪装隐藏起来的衣服。这确实非常合乎情理。我觉得外向者就是那些支撑着有趣的珠宝Etsy店铺，以及印有标语的T恤店的人，因为他们在寻找一种尽可能生动地展现自己个性、几乎就像蝴蝶一样吸引人们目光的方式。让我们朝着相反的方向看。如果外向者更倾向于那种风格，那这对于那些衣服总是专业、熨烫平整且非常整洁的人意味着什么呢？这些人就像是责任心的标志。根据2021年的同一研究，这些人虽然具有很强的社交意识，虽然他们很自信，但他们似乎更倾向于经典的正装风格。
They seem to represent themselves as organized, as reliable, as punctual. They use fashion to signal competence and order. You want to know the weirdest fashion psychology fact I learned the other day. If someone is wearing a wristwatch, that can. can actually tell you something about their personality. So a 2015 study looking at, I think over 700 people found that people who wear wristwatches are more conscientious, more responsible, more rule following compared to people who don't wear wristwatches. They're typically less conscientious and they're less likely to follow the rules. So there you go. If you want to look good
他们似乎将自己表现为有条理、可靠、守时的人。他们用时尚来传递能力和秩序的信号。你想知道我前几天学到的最奇怪的时尚心理学事实吗？如果有人戴着手表，那其实可以告诉你一些关于他们性格的信息。2025年的一项针对（我想是）700多人的研究发现，与不戴手表的人相比，戴手表的人更有责任心、更负责任、更守规矩。不戴手表的人通常责任心较弱，也不太可能遵守规则。所以你看。如果你想在面试中表现得体，
in a job interview, show up wearing a wristwatch because it signals a lot of really good things. it's just so weird how you know fashion and and personality kind of connects in that way something as simple as a wristwatch like that's like a peek into who you are as a person two final conclusions from that same study
戴着手表去吧，因为它传递了很多非常好的信号。时尚和个性以这种方式联系在一起，这真是太奇怪了，仅仅像一块手表这样简单的事物——就像是对你作为一个人的内在的一窥。来自同一研究的最后两个结论，
just because it was just such a magnificent one we have to go into detail on a little bit more people who are high in agreeableness they were also more likely to wear less dramatic or unusual clothing so they more likely to want to
因为这个发现实在是太棒了，我们必须更详细地探讨一下：在宜人性上得分较高的人，他们也更有可能穿着不那么戏剧化或不同寻常的服装。所以他们更有可能想要
blend in or wear traditional clothing. Obviously, they want to be friends with everyone. They're agreeable. Anything that makes them stick out or makes them controversial is not something they're going to be leaning towards. And people who are high in neuroticism actually used clothing as a form of emotional regulation or as security blankets. So apparently, these individuals are more likely to be self-conscious. People high in neuroticism are more likely to be self-conscious and to engage in body surveillance, so they may actually use specific clothing styles to manage their body image. And on top of that, their social anxiety or general anxiety, often opting for safe choices, often opting for things that are comfortable or that avoid drawing unwanted scrutiny or judgments
融入人群或穿着传统服装。显然，他们希望和每个人都做朋友。他们很好相处。任何让他们显得特立独行或引发争议的事情都不会是他们的倾心之选。而在神经质上得分较高的人，实际上是将服装用作情绪调节的形式或安全毯。显然，这些人更有可能缺乏安全感。神经质得分较高的人更容易自我意识过剩，并进行身体监视，因此他们实际上可能会利用特定的服装风格来管理自己的体象。除此之外，他们的社交焦虑或一般焦虑往往使他们倾向于稳妥的选择，往往倾向于那些舒适的、或者能够避免吸引他人不必要的审视或判断的衣物，
from other people. So that's like a whole profile of all the big five and like how your measurement on that might turn the dial on your clothing choices. Essentially, it's this thing we've been repeating. What you choose to wear can be a really subtle personality cue. And now that is not permission to go and judge or assess every single person you are meeting based on this profile. Like, that must, like, if they're wearing a wristwatch or if they're not wearing a wrist watch, like, that must say that they aren't a kind person or whatever. Like, these aren't rules to follow, people can very easily be outliers or shift from the norm here. It's just one singular peak into fashion psychology. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is
因此，这就是大五人格的整体画像，以及你在这些维度上的测量结果如何转动你服装选择的表盘。本质上，这就是我们一直在重复的事情：你选择穿什么可以成为一个非常微妙的性格暗示。现在，这并不是说你可以根据这个画像去评判或评估你遇到的每一个人。比如，如果他们戴着手表或者没有戴手表，那绝不能说明他们不是一个善良的人，或者其他什么。这些都不是必须遵循的规则，人们很容易成为特例或偏离常规。这只是通往时尚心理学的一扇独特之窗。《2%》。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇妙的现代世界中，我将剖析精神韧性、体能以及构建心理弹性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的
also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
人。请收听《2%》。搜索数字2%，即可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆（Lil' Kim）胸部的那一幕吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？
fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的霹雳可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时都可以聊当天的可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack,
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上桌面了，所以。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的正是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
生活变成了赢与输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹是因为想做个好人而去这样做。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
加入我科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她说法中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场为证明真相而长达数年的法庭之战。埃伦女士，你对这个特定测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要。惹恼乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在新一季的
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season
《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一下。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。解决问题。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。
of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think clothing, again, why it's so important is because it's one of the quickest ways that we can communicate not just our personality, but our identity. Before you've even spoken, like your outfit can signal to other people, I see myself as this kind of person,
将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逍遥法外的。他会得到应有的下场。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。我认为服装之所以如此重要，是因为它是我们传达的不仅是性格、更是自我身份最快捷的方式之一。在你开口说话之前，你的服装就可以向其他人发出信号：我将自己视为这样的人，
or I see myself as one of you, or I want to be seen as one of you, or as one of these kinds of people. Clothing and the role it plays in social cohesion and social conformity is another major a piece of this puzzle. So much of personal style is tied up in who we want to align with. Subcultures, subgroups, little tribes with their own codes and aesthetics and shared references and their own music taste and values and political views. A band tea isn't just a band tea. It's a sign of the world or the subgroup that you're in. And with that becomes a lot of information about certain likes or dislikes. A particular hiking shoe. It's not just a shoe.
或者我把自己看作你们中的一员，或者我希望被视为你们中的一员，或者被视为这类人中的一员。服装在社会凝聚力和社会从众性中所起的作用是这个拼图的另一个重要部分。个人风格的很大一部分都与我们想要与之结盟的对象息息相关。亚文化、子群体、有着各自密码、美学、共同参考系、各自音乐品味、价值观和政治观的小部落。一件乐队T恤不仅仅是一件乐队T恤。它是你所处的世界或子群体的标志。随之而来的是大量关于某些喜好或厌恶的信息。一双特定的徒步鞋。它不仅仅是一双鞋。
It's a signal that you love the outdoors, but you also love the city and that these are the two sides of you, like, blending in together. There is something for everybody in that sense. A certain silhouette isn't just a silhouette. It can reference a scene, an error, a movement, a set of beliefs about class, about what gender even means. Clothes are as political and as psychological as they are fun. And where we can really see that is in women's, athleteia wear trends. You know, the rise of conservatism came at the same time as the rise in Pilates wear and in pink matching sets and ballet silhouettes, things that are very traditionally feminine.
它是一个信号，表明你热爱户外活动，但你也热爱城市，而这是你的两个面，完美地融合在了一起。从这个意义上说，每个人都能找到适合自己的东西。某种剪影绝不仅仅是一个剪影。它可以指代一个场景、一个时代、一场运动、一套关于阶级、甚至关于性别意味着什么的信念。服装既具有政治性、心理性，又充满趣味。我们真正能看到这一点的地方是在女性的运动休闲装潮流中。你知道，保守主义的兴起与普拉提服装、粉色配套套装以及芭蕾舞剪影（即那些非常传统的女性化事物）的兴起是同时发生的。
Now what's trending more in this day and age is, especially for women, trekking pants, double-stacked sports bras, practical hardcore hiking shoes, like Gore-Tech. It's like this real signal of that pushback, right? This pushback against traditional feminine ideals, the fight back, the literal protest against authoritarianism that is like taking place in the world. You can really read a lot about what is happening in society based on fashion trends and based on where people kind of present themselves on the spectrum. Everything you choose to wear has a message contained if you look for it. Sometimes it's explicit, like a slogan or a flag or a badge or a university merchandise,
而如今这个时代更流行的是，尤其是对女性而言，徒步裤、双层运动内衣、实用的硬核徒步鞋，比如Gore-Tex。这就像是这种强烈推回的信号，对吧？这种对传统女性理想的推回，这种反抗，对世界上正在发生的威权主义的字面抗议。根据时尚趋势以及人们在光谱上的呈现位置，你可以从中学到很多关于社会正在发生的事情的信息。如果你去寻找的话，你选择穿的每样东西都包含着一个信息。有时它是明确的，比如标语、旗帜、徽章或大学纪念品，
your literal favorite band on a T-shirt, that's an explicit message of how you want to be seen. And sometimes it is more coded. It's like anytime you see somebody with like visible mending or stitching, that might be a sign of sustainability values or, you know, of class or, you know, of class or, income level. Or if you wear athletics wear outside of the gym, you know, that might be a sign of how you, again, how you want to represent yourself as a healthy person. Or if you blend typically masculine and typically feminine clothes together, that signals gender nonconformity. I'm giving you a lot of examples just to say that the brain pays attention to this stuff. And it pays attention to the stuff,
T恤上你字面意义上最喜欢的乐队，这就是你希望如何被看到的明确信息。有时它是更带密码的。比如任何时候你看到有人穿着有明显补丁或缝线衣服，那可能是对可持续发展价值观的标志，或者是阶级的标志，或者是收入水平的标志。或者如果你在健身房外面穿运动休闲装，你知道，那可能标志着你想再次把自己表现为一个健康的人。或者如果你将通常属于男性的衣服和通常属于女性的衣服混搭在一起，这就发出了性别不符合常规的信号。我举这么多例子只是想说明，大脑会注意到这些东西。它注意到这些东西，
yes, to categorize and to understand people, but mainly to use clothing as a mental shortcut and to be able to then identify the people you want to relate to or the tribe you want to belong to and those that you don't see yourself close to or as a part of. Your brain often scans for these familiar cues because we're naturally attracted to similarity. So somebody who is wearing a similar silhouette, similar colors, similar brands, a similar uniform to you, that is a visual marker of somebody who's going to be part of your in-group. And when we find them, that registers as safety and that registers as belonging. One distinct example of this and how this happens is like,
是的，为了分类和理解人们，但主要是为了将服装用作心理捷径，从而能够识别出你想与之建立联系的人或你想从属的部落，以及那些你认为与自己无关或不属于你的人。你的大脑经常扫描这些熟悉的线索，因为我们天生就被相似性所吸引。所以那些穿着相似剪影、相似颜色、相似品牌、与你穿着相似制服的人，就是那些将成为你的内群体成员的视觉标记。当我们找到他们时，这就会被登记为安全感和归属感。这方面的一个明显例子以及这种情况是如何发生的，就是庞克。
and how identity forms through clothes is like punk. And what made punk so big, predominantly in London in like the 70s and 80s, it was like this counterculture reaction to economic and to like social unrest during this period. And designers like Vivian Westwood, like they really had their rise during this time because they utilized a lot of this like anti-monarchy, anti-establishment, anti-capitalist messaging that a lot of people were getting behind and kind of flock to and like the androgynous silhouettes and the ripped clothing and the tartan that was ripped in the non-traditional hairstyles and the safety pin visual that represented to people a kind of philosophy. and a kind of subgenre of people or people with certain beliefs that they wanted to gravitate towards it.
朋克之所以如此庞大，主要是在70年代和80年代的伦敦，它是当时面对经济和社会动荡的一种反主流文化反应。像薇薇安·韦斯特伍德这样的设计师在这个时期真正崛起了，因为他们利用了许多反君主制、反建制、反资本主义的信息，很多人都支持并蜂拥而至，还有那些雌雄同体的轮廓、破洞的衣服、撕裂的格子呢、非传统的发型，以及向人们展示某种哲学和某一特定人群或有着特定信仰的人的子流派的别针视觉，人们希望被其吸引。
And so it is used almost like a badge. What we wear is symbolic of how we want to be seen, which then also impacts how people treat us. And that in itself either strengthens our identity or diminishes it or, you know, it either reinforces the cycle or, again, through that learned association, it kind of teaches us or, guides us into being somebody else. Here's something super interesting. A 2025 study found that we often dress more group aligned when we feel socially uncertain. That is why micro-trends and fast fashion caters more towards younger people. Yes, because it's cheaper, but also because they don't know who they are yet or where they fit in.
因此，它几乎被用作徽章。我们的穿着象征着我们希望如何被看待，这反过来又影响了人们对待我们的方式。而这本身要么巩固了我们的身份，要么削弱了它，或者，你知道的，它要么强化了这个循环，要么，再次通过那种习得的联想，它教导我们或引导我们成为别人。这里有个超级有趣的事情。2025年的一项研究发现，当我们感到社交不确定时，我们的着装往往更倾向于与群体保持一致。这就是为什么微趋势和快时尚更迎合年轻人的原因。是的，因为它们更便宜，但也因为他们还不知道自己是谁，或者不知道自己适合哪里。
They also don't have a sense of personal style because they don't have that identity. So they're really quick to buy whatever is trending because of that lack of, you know, identity stability, regardless of whether it's made poorly, because it doesn't really matter. They don't need it to fit. They don't need it to be something they wear in like three months because their identity is probably going to change as fast as the trend is. It's also why teenagers or people in high school or younger people, that's where subgroups really start, often in younger groups of individuals, because their identity is so unscernation, stable, there's this greatest sense of wanting to align with a subgroup or a type of fashion or
他们也没有个人风格的意识，因为他们没有那种身份认同。所以由于缺乏这种身份的稳定性，他们非常乐意购买任何流行的东西，不管它做工有多么糟糕，因为这其实并不重要。他们不需要它合身，他们不需要它成为他们能在三个月内还能穿的东西，因为他们的身份可能会像潮流一样变化得一样快。这也是为什么青少年或高中生或更年轻的人——子群体往往从较年轻的个人群体开始，因为他们的身份非常不稳定，他们有着最强烈的愿望，想要与一个子群体或某种通过时尚表现出来的、稳定的时尚类型或身份类型保持一致。
a type of identity that is represented through fashion, that is stable. And that means one thing and that can be categorized because it's kind of like this life raft for them. It's kind of like this thing that they can hold onto when everything else about them is kind of like floating around. similar to this, it's also why when we enter a new social environment, we really feel the need to reinstate or reinforce our personal style or reinvent it. So that's why we go and buy new outfits for a new job. It's why freshmen always buy new wardrobes before they start university. It's why someone who just moved to Berlin wants to dress more Berlin. This is what is called enclosed cognition. It is a psychological phenomenon coined by this man, Harjo Adams,
这意味着一件事，并且可以被归类，因为它对他们来说就像是一艘救生艇。当他们身上的一切都在四处漂浮时，这就像是他们可以紧紧抓住的东西。与此类似，这也是为什么当我们进入一个新的社交环境时，我们真的觉得有必要重新树立或巩固我们的个人风格，或者彻底重塑它。这就是为什么我们为新工作去买新衣服。这就是为什么大一新生在开始大学生活前总是会买新衣橱。这也是为什么一个刚搬到柏林的人想要穿得更像柏林人。这就是所谓的“服装认知”（enclosed cognition）。这是一个由这个人——哈乔·亚当斯——提出的心理学现象。
whereby the symbolic meaning of our clothing actually influences our cognitive processes, which in turn affects our thoughts, affects our feelings, affects our behavior. The researcher who coined this term in his research, he basically discovered that this can influence everything from our emotional state to how we see ourselves to our intelligence. What you wear can literally influence how smart you feel and how smart you are. In this now very famous 2012 experiment, participants were essentially asked to complete a bunch of attentional and memory tasks, either wearing a doctor's lab coat or not. And somewhere even told, like, the lab coat was like a painter's coat. And then some people didn't wear it at all.
即服装的象征意义实际上会影响我们的认知过程，进而影响我们的思想、感受和行为。在研究中创造这个词的研究人员基本上发现，这可以影响从我们的情绪状态到我们如何看待自己以及智力的方方面面。你穿的衣服真的会影响你觉得自己有多聪明以及你实际有多聪明。在这个现在非常著名的 2012 年实验中，参与者基本上被要求完成一堆注意力和记忆任务，穿不穿医生的实验白大褂都可以。甚至有些人被告知，白大褂就像画家的外套一样。然后有些人根本不穿。
The people who went into these tasks wearing the doctor's coat did significantly better on those tasks compared to the others. And there was a large sample size here. And the only thing that was different, yeah, maybe there was slight personality and intelligence differences, but that was definitely controlled for. The only major difference was that they dress smarter. This is why things like dopamine dressing or dressing up for a date or dressing for the job you want, not the job you have, can actually change the way you feel in those situations. A 2010, a 2010, not 2020, 2010 study from the,
那些穿着医生白大褂完成这些任务的人，在这些任务上的表现明显优于其他人。这里有很大的样本量。而唯一不同的地方在于，是的，也许存在微小的个性和智力差异，但这绝对是得到了控制的。唯一的重大区别是他们穿得更得体。这就是为什么多巴胺穿装、盛装约会或为了你想要的工作而不是你现在的工作而打扮等事情，实际上可以改变你在这些情况下的感受。2010 年，2010 年，不是 2020 年，而是 2010 年的一项研究来自，
University of Huddersfield actually found that certain clothes, if they were the participants' favorites, actually served as emotional regulators like we were talking about before, meaning that the participants were more likely to feel able to, you know, they were more likely to feel in control of their emotions and in control of their environment if the outfit they were wearing was their favorite. Nothing else changed, just the outfit. And again, I could cite so many more sources like this that essentially all say the same thing and reach the same conclusion. Clothing is a mental leather that we can use to direct our emotional state. And we can therefore take advantage of that knowledge to change our mood in situations where we want more control using our clothes.
哈uddersfield（哈德斯菲尔德）大学实际上发现，某些衣服如果是参与者最喜欢的，实际上可以像我们之前谈到的那样充当情感调节器，这意味着如果参与者穿的衣服是他们最喜欢的，他们就更有可能觉得能够，你知道的，他们更有可能觉得自己能掌控自己的情绪和环境。其他什么都没有变，只有衣服。再说一次，我可以引述更多这样的来源，它们基本上都说明了同一件事并得出了相同的结论。服装是一种心理皮带，我们可以用它来引导我们的情绪状态。因此，我们可以利用这些知识，在我们想要获得更多控制权的情况下，利用我们的衣服来改变我们的情绪。
Like, we can literally feel more confident, more competent, more safe, more everything based on what we're wearing. And you can do that both ways, right? You can, yes, choose what you're going to wear to best embody an emotional state you want to have. You can actually also examine the clothes that you are unconsciously choosing at a certain time in your life to tell you what you're avoiding or tell you what you're feeling. Like when you suddenly find yourself unable to wear your favorite pair of jeans or completely avoiding any tight clothing, that's saying something about your self-esteem. That's something you need to focus on. Or when you find yourself leaning more towards revealing tight, colorful clothing, maybe this is a natural sign that, like, you're really feeling yourself right now.
比如，根据我们穿的衣服，我们可以真正感到更自信、更有能力、更安全、更面面俱到。你可以双向做到这一点，对吧？你可以，是的，选择你要穿的衣服，来最好地体现你想要拥有的情绪状态。你实际上还可以检查你在生活中的某个特定时期无意识选择的衣服，以告诉你你在逃避什么，或者告诉你你的感受。就像当你突然发现自己无法穿上自己最喜欢的牛仔裤，或者完全避开任何紧身衣物时，这说明了你的自尊问题。这是你需要关注的事情。或者当你发现自己更倾向于暴露、紧身、色彩鲜艳的衣服时，也许这是一个自然的信号，表明，比如，你现在真的很自我感觉良好。
Maybe it's time to, like, schedule some dates. Maybe it's time to, like, get out there because people are going to see this, like, enigmatic, amazing side of you and, like, the side of you that feels very, very alive. You know what I find interesting, though? What I really find interesting is that despite all this, like we know personal style is supposed to be self-expression and it has this effect and it's so emotionally powerful. And yet, there are so many moments where, like, we know what we want to wear
也许是时候，比如，安排一些约会了。也许是时候，比如，走出去，因为人们会看到这面，比如，你神秘、惊艳的一面，以及，比如，你感觉非常非常充满活力的一面。你知道我觉得有趣的是什么吗？我真正觉得有趣的是，尽管有这一切，就像我们知道个人风格应该是一种自我表达，它有这种效果，而且它在情感上如此强大。然而，有很多时候，比如，我们知道自己想穿什么
and we know it's going to make us feel good or we know that this is something we like and then we don't do it. This is this weird contradiction with personal style. We have personal style and sometimes we avoid our style. I feel like right now I have all these really cool clothes that I really like in theory that I think represent me, but I never wear them because they're too out there or they're too different and I'll
而且我们知道它会让我们感觉良好，或者我们知道这是我们喜欢的东西，然后我们却没有去做。这就是个人风格中这种奇怪的矛盾。我们有个人风格，有时我们却在回避我们的风格。我觉得现在我所有这些真正喜欢的、在理论上我认为代表我的酷炫衣服，但我从不穿它们，因为它们太出挑了，或者它们太与众不同了，我会
try them on every few weeks and I'll seriously consider wearing them and then I'll like put them back in my closet. We so often choose the safe outfit. The one that we, yes, no, we feel comfortable in, but the one we know won't get any comments, the one that won't make us feel too visible because a lot of the time, I think we're dressing not for ourselves, but we're dressing for the imagined audience, right? Most of us, I know I do, carry around with us a mental panel of judges, whether they are colleagues, whether they are strangers, whether they are friends or an ex, people on Instagram. There's this panel of people who we almost present every outfit we wear too before we walk out the door. It's this weird, like they're not there, but it's this weird social monitoring that we have
每隔几周试穿一次，然后认真考虑穿它们，接着我会像把它们放回衣橱里一样。我们经常选择安全的衣服。那种我们，是的，不，我们穿着感觉舒服的衣服，但那种我们知道不会招来任何评论的衣服，那种不会让我们感觉过于显眼的衣服，因为很多时候，我认为我们打扮不是为了自己，而是为了想象中的观众，对吧？我们大多数人，我知道我是这样，随身携带一个由法官组成的心理小组，无论是同事、陌生人、朋友还是前任、Instagram 上的人。在走出门之前，几乎我们穿的每一套衣服都要向这个评审团展示。这是一种奇怪的，就像他们不在场，但这是我们所拥有的奇怪的社会监督
in our head. How is the general public going to feel about my outfit? We put that before how we're going to feel. And that is why we constantly come back towards three or four outfits that we feel the safest in because we feel they are the easiest. What's important to know is that we tend to really overestimate how much other people notice us. Psychologists, I think we spoke about this only a couple of weeks ago, call this spotlight effect. It's that feeling that if you wear something bold, everyone's going to stare, everyone's going to comment, everyone's going to judge you or remember you, everyone will see how, you know, the fabric pulls slightly or like that your bra sticks out a bit, like, that it's a bit different from what you're used to. They know it,
在我们的脑海里。公众会对我的服装作何感想？我们将这一点置于我们的感受之前。这就是为什么我们不断回到那三四套让我们感觉最安全的服装，因为我们觉得它们最简单。重要的是要知道，我们往往会大大高估别人注意到我们的程度。心理学家，我想我们几周前才谈过这个，称之为聚光灯效应。那种感觉是，如果你穿得很醒目，每个人都会盯着看，每个人都会发表评论，每个人都会评判你或记住你，每个人都会看到，你知道的，面料微微拉扯的样子，或者你的胸罩露出一小截的样子，比如，它和你习惯的有点不同。他们知道，
we know it. Like, it's this weird thing. So we should just take it off. Like, we just shouldn't wear that. it's so funny because in reality, most people do not give a flying F. They are not thinking about you. They are thinking about themselves. If you listened to our How to Stop Taking Things Personally episode, you'll know this very well. Only 22% of our daily thoughts are spent thinking about other people. And often, even when we are thinking about other people, we're thinking about their behavior in relation to ourselves.
我们知道。就像，这是一种奇怪的事情。所以我们应该直接脱掉它。就像，我们就不应该穿那个。太搞笑了，因为实际上，大多数人根本不在乎。他们不在乎你。他们考虑的是他们自己。如果你听过我们的《如何停止将事情个人化》那一集，你就会对这一点非常清楚。我们每天只有 22% 的时间用于思考其他人。而且通常情况下，即使我们在想其他人，我们也是在想他们的行为与我们自身的关系。
So if we're judging somebody else's outfit, it's not really about them. It's about us and our lack of confidence to wear that. If we are looking at somebody else's coat, perhaps part of it is because we wish we had the boldness to wear it. Social media has definitely exacerbated this. It's definitely made this harder. And it's partially responsible for, I also think, how fast trends come and go these days.
所以，如果我们对别人的服装评头论足，那其实与他们无关。这关乎我们自己，以及我们穿那件衣服缺乏自信。如果我们看着别人的外套，也许部分原因是因为我们希望自己有胆量穿上它。社交媒体无疑加剧了这种现象。它绝对让这件事变得更难了。我认为，这也是当今潮流来去匆匆的部分原因。
Because we are all judging ourselves based on this impossible, what's hot, what's not that changes every few weeks. Like what was the print that was like trending a couple ways ago? Like deer print. I was seeing all these articles about like, deer print is in,
因为我们都在根据这种不可能的标准来评判自己，什么是流行，什么是不流行，每隔几周就会改变一次。比如，前几天流行的印花是什么？就像鹿纹。我看到所有这些关于鹿纹正流行的文章，
deer print is the next thing. And then just last week there was this TikTok being like, Deer print is cheap. Deer print is last season. You can't win. When you are judging yourself against the imagined current status
鹿纹是下一个潮流。然后就在上周，TikTok 上出现了这样的视频：鹿纹很廉价。鹿纹已经是上一季的了。你根本赢不了。当你用想象中的当前地位来评判自己
or current state of what is cool and what's not, as soon as like you adopt the trend, the trend goes out of style because the moment that more than 50% of people are wearing, what is cool, it's no longer cool anymore because it's gotten to public and it's no longer something people can gatekeep. The author Paula Deelia, she talks about the fact that social media fashion culture has actually increased self-objectification and comparison pressures. And that actually means that style and fashion has suddenly become incredibly basic. And that a lot of our personal style choices are really based on like what looks good based on a trend, what we think
或者说什么是酷什么不酷的现状，一旦你采用了这个潮流，这个潮流就会过时，因为当超过 50% 的人都在穿什么是酷的东西时，它就不再酷了，因为它变得太大众化了，不再是人们可以垄断的东西。作家宝拉·德利娅（Paula Deelia）谈到了这样一个事实：社交媒体时尚文化实际上增加了自我客体化和比较压力。这实际上意味着风格和时尚突然变得极其基础。而且，我们很多的个人风格选择，其实是基于根据潮流什么好看、我们认为
will photograph well, what we think we'll get likes or what we think will look right next to everybody else. Most of our fashion choices are for the the feed. And the more you lose touch with what you actually enjoy or feel best in, the worse it becomes and the harder it is to come back. And the harder it is for society as a whole to have originality. I read this other article that talks about this thing called aesthetic convergence or a narrowing of what is most often shown, liked, copied and worn. So essentially, this researcher did all this analysis and found that we're all starting to look the same, not just like physically in terms of our faces and our bodies, but fashion, because it's becoming more and more
什么会拍得好看、我们认为会获得点赞，或者我们认为在其他人旁边看起来很对。我们的大部分时尚选择都是为了动态消息。你越是与自己真正喜欢或感觉最好的东西失去联系，情况就会变得越糟，想要找回自我也就越难。对于整个社会而言，保持原创性也就越难。我还读了另一篇文章，讨论了一种叫做美学趋同的现象，或者说最常被展示、喜欢、效仿和穿着的风格正在变窄。因此，本质上，这位研究人员做了所有的分析，发现我们所有人开始看起来都一样，不仅是我们的脸和身体在物理上如此，而且在时尚方面，因为它变得越来越
trend-based and competitive, brands know that the only way to make a profit is to follow what is trending and what people like in the moment. They're not going to create something different or new because that's going to be less likely to sell. It's not the current style and who's not wearing the current style. So all our options are becoming increasingly similar. And increasing siloed into categories. So there's like the cool girl brand, the athletic brand, and they don't really have as much crossover, which is why we feel like we have less and less choice. It also explains why I know I've personally noticed trends are always just one degree, a one degree shift from the last trend. Like they're never that revolutionary. Take like animal print. A couple years ago it was
以潮流为导向且极具竞争性，品牌深知获取利润的唯一途径就是紧跟当下的流行趋势和人们的喜好。他们不会创造出与众不同或崭新的东西，因为那样卖出去的可能性更小。这不是当前的风格，而谁又没有穿着当前的风格呢。因此，我们的所有选择变得越来越相似。并且越来越多地被划分到各个类别中。所以有诸如酷女孩品牌、运动品牌，它们之间没有太多的跨界融合，这就是为什么我们觉得我们的选择越来越少的原因。这也解释了为什么我个人注意到潮流永远只是上一潮流的一度偏移，仅此而已。它们从来都不是那么具有革命性。以动物纹为例。几年前它是
cow. And then the slight change was that it's cheetah. And like now it's deer. or like it went from like matching gym sets to like clean girl Pilates sets to like Y2K Yoga Mums set. Nothing is ever a full sweep. It's always just this tiny change. No brand, no fashion house is ever going to move too far because they don't want to fall off the balance of something that is fresh and new without being too different and therefore difficult to market.
奶牛纹。然后稍微一变就成了猎豹纹。然后现在是鹿纹。或者就像从成套的运动装变成干净女孩普拉提套装，再到 Y2K 瑜伽妈妈套装。从来没有什么是彻底大换血的。永远只是这种微小的改变。没有任何品牌、没有任何时装屋会迈出太大的步伐，因为他们不想打破平衡，去尝试那些既新鲜又崭新、却又不会因为过于与众不同而难以推销的东西。
Like this is a question I genuinely want you to ask yourself, when was the last time you saw something new? It's not because people aren't inventive. It's definitely not because people are boring. It's because we are social learners. And fashion is one of the fastest moving social signals that we have to conform to. You know, in social psychology, conformity is what happens when we adjust our behavior to what the group expects. That is what's happening with our fashion choices. Sometimes that's because we genuinely believe the group is right.
就像这是一个我真心想问你自己的问题，你上一次看到新鲜事物是什么时候？这并不是因为人们缺乏创造力。绝对不是因为人们无趣。这是因为我们是社会化学习者。而时尚是我们必须顺应的移动速度最快的社会信号之一。你知道，在社会心理学中，从众是指当我们调整自己的行为以符合群体期望时发生的事情。这就是我们的时尚选择正在发生的事情。有时这是因为我们真诚地相信群体是正确的。
This is known as informational influence. you know, if everybody's doing it, they probably know what's good. And sometimes it's just because we don't actually like the trend. We just fear rejection. This is known as normative influence. So I don't want to look weird. Even though I hate those Adanas Sambas or whatever, like everybody's wearing them, so I better wear them. Either way, the result is the same. We all drift towards the center of what feels socially safe. And clothing is especially vulnerable because it is so public. And because it is tied in yet again to our identity and to how we see ourselves. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
这就是所谓的 informational influence（信息性影响）。你知道的，如果每个人都在这样做，他们可能知道什么是好的。有时只是因为我们并不真的喜欢这个潮流。我们只是害怕被拒绝。这被称为规范性影响。所以我不想看起来很怪异。尽管我讨厌那些阿迪达斯桑巴鞋或其他什么鞋，但既然每个人都在穿，我最好也穿。无论哪种情况，结果都是一样的。我们都会不由自主地向感到社会安全的中心靠拢。服装尤其脆弱，因为它太公开了。而且因为它再次与我们的身份以及我们如何看待自己紧密相连。2%。这就是当旁边也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
满足、更健康的。收听《2%》。即在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 TWO%。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（指捏）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格lish（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作客，大谈 80 年代的快克（可卡因）。
To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出它们之间有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》（难走的路），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们仍在追逐，却不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines），我们在我的新播客
podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring
《Learn the Hardway》中就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的
inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
前后矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在很大程度上伪造了这个特定的测试两次。我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either.
劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要招惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万不要招惹她的朋友。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这新一季的《闺蜜》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以他们决定自己动手。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. If you want to reclaim your personal style, here are four really easy ways to do it. Number one, reduce the wardrobe clutter.
我说，哦，见鬼，才不。我发誓我会成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你想找回你的个人风格，这里有四个非常简单的方法。第一，减少衣橱杂物。
You know those pieces that I was talking about that we own and we would never wear? but we just keep them because they're cool or because we bought them because they were like the trend and like we want to be the kind of person who's going to wear them but we don't for me it's like this big fluffy hat and a couple other things but the fluffy hat in particular these pieces are mental clutter and they are blocking your personal style by increasing a sense of decision fatigue essentially giving you more options to consider when that option isn't really a true option but you feel like you have to consider it you feel like it's kind of there and when you do finally choose it, you're never going to be comfortable in it anyways.
你知道我刚才说的那些我们拥有却永远不会穿的衣服吗？但我们只是留着它们，因为它们很酷，或者因为我们买它们是因为它们是潮流，而且我们想成为那种会穿它们的人，但我们没有——对我来说，就像这顶毛茸茸的大帽子和其他一些东西，但这顶毛茸茸的大帽子尤其如此，这些衣服是精神杂物，它们通过增加决策疲劳感来阻碍你的个人风格，本质上是让你在选项其实并非真正选项时考虑更多选项，但你觉得你必须考虑它们，你觉得它们就在那里，当你最终选择它时，你无论如何都不会穿着它感到舒适。
So basically you're just slowing down the process of getting dressed every morning. So I need you to do a closet purge. When you do a closet purge, what I need you to ask yourself is, have I worn this in the past three months, or have I worn it at all? And if it's not something like a big winter coat or like your wedding dress or a summer dress, you know you're going to wear heaps when the sun is back up, sell it on Deepup, give it to a friend, sell it on Vinted, start not from scratch, but from your favorites. Basically get down to that capsule wardrobe.
所以基本上你只是放慢了每天早上穿衣打扮的过程。所以我需要你进行一次衣橱大扫除。当你进行衣橱大扫除时，我需要你问自己的是：我在过去三个月里穿过这个吗，或者我穿过它吗？如果它不是像一件厚重的冬衣、你的婚纱或夏裙这样你知道等阳光再次普照时你会穿无数次的衣服，那就把它在 Depop 上卖掉，送给朋友，或者在 Vinted 上卖掉。不要从零开始，而是从你最喜欢的衣服开始。基本上就是精简到那个胶囊衣橱。
And speaking of favorites, also notice the things you keep rebuying in a slightly different font or in a slightly different version. I realized this the other day when I was looking back at pictures of me from 2022 for this, like, I don't know, something I was doing on Instagram. and I was looking at this photo and I realized I was wearing the exact same outfit in those pictures as the one I was wearing just like as I was looking on my phone. And none of those items were the same items. Like I had replaced my wardrobe from 2022 to 2026 and I was still wearing the same thing just not with the same clothes.
说到最喜欢的衣服，还要注意那些你总是以稍微不同的字体或稍微不同的版本不断回购的东西。前几天我在看 2022 年自己的照片时意识到了这一点，为了这个，我不知道，我在 Instagram 上做的一些事情。我看着这张照片，我意识到我在这些照片中穿的衣服和我现在看手机时穿的完全一样。而且这些单品中没有一件是相同的单品。就像我从 2022 年到 2026 年更换了我的衣橱，我穿的仍然是同样的东西，只是衣服不一样了。
And I genuinely, I wish I could, you could see this side by side. It was like boot cut baggy white jeans, cropped kind of like, cream gray cashmere type v-necks sweater, literally the same shoes. And I was like, why did I throw those pieces away only to replace them? Like three years later. I think it was because at some stage, like, I tried to reinvent my style and I tried to like do this whole like overhaul of what I wore. And it was this weird thing where it's like, this is my equilibrium that I keep coming back
我真的，我希望我能，你可以并排看到这个。就像微喇宽松白牛仔裤、剪裁微短的乳灰色羊绒V领毛衣，鞋子简直一模一样。当时我想，我为什么要把那些衣服扔掉，结果三年后又买回一模一样的来替换？我想这是因为在某个阶段，比如，我试图重塑我的风格，我试图对我穿的衣服进行彻底的大改造。这是一种奇怪的现象，就像，这是我不断回到的平衡状态
to. Like as much as I try and be this kind of person or whatever, like there are some core things. things that I'm always going to have in my closet. I know for me that is like a chunky blue sweater, a striped blue collared shirt. I literally used to wear them to high school when I was 15. I looked like a little businesswoman and like a pair of blue jeans. And if you go through your pictures, you will notice the things you always end up buying and wearing, even as the trends change. And that is your personal style. That is the base of your wardrobe. So if you're going to invest in anything, invest in having good quality versions of those historical style pieces that you can
。不管我怎么努力成为这样的人或者其他什么，总有一些核心的东西是我衣橱里永远都会有的。我知道对我的衣橱来说，那是一件厚重的蓝色毛衣、一件条纹蓝色翻领衬衫。我 15 岁上高中时就经常穿它们。我看起来像个小女商人，还有一条蓝色牛仔裤。如果你翻看你的照片，你会发现无论潮流如何变化，你最终总是会买和穿的那些东西。这就是你的个人风格。那是你衣橱的基础。因此，如果你要在任何事情上投资，那就投资于拥有良好品质的那些历史风格单品的版本，你可以
structure the rest of your wardrobe around. I would also say create your own style archetype. Architectives are everywhere in society, everywhere in psychology, from Jung to great mythology, to the seven feminine archetypes, you know, the maiden, the mother, the mystic, the huntress, blah blah blah blah blah it is such a great mental shortcut for figuring out what you want to wear and why you want to wear it and you can make your own fashion archetype this is how you're going to do it you're going to begin with some descriptors what do you need your clothes to do for you day to day what do your clothes need to make you feel like and look like comfortable flexible do they need to make you look effortless smart you know if you're an artist um what does that mean maybe if you're
围绕它们来构建你的其余衣橱。我还要说，创造你自己的风格原型。原型在社会中随处可见，在心理学中随处可见，从荣格到伟大的神话，到七种女性原型，你知道的，少女、母亲、神秘主义者、女猎人，啦啦啦啦啦，这真是寻找你想穿什么以及为什么想穿什么的绝佳心理捷径，你可以打造你自己的时尚原型，方法如下：你将从一些描述词开始。日常生活中你需要你的衣服为你做什么？你的衣服需要让你感觉如何、看起来如何？舒适、灵活？它们需要让你看起来毫不费力、精明干练吗？你知道，如果你是个艺术家，嗯，那意味着什么？也许如果你是
social worker. It has to be understated, grounded if you work in carpentry. Choose three words that are essentials for your clothes and those are your basis. So mine are like comfortable, smart and I would say unassuming. That's just what the preference for what I need my clothes to do for me. Then add your aspirational words. So think of five people whose style you like really admire. Stevie Nix, Jennifer Lawrence, ASAP Rocky, Emma Chamberlain, I don't know, Adam Sandler, whatever. Five people whose clothes you really admire. Get on Pinterest. Get on any platform.
社会工作者。如果你从事木工工作，它必须是低调的、接地气的。选择三个对你的衣服至关重要的词，这些就是你的基础。所以我的词是：舒适、精明，我还要加上朴实无华。这只是我对我的衣服需要为我做的事情的偏好。然后添加你的向心词。所以想想五个你真正钦佩其风格的人。史蒂薇·尼克斯（Stevie Nicks）、詹妮弗·劳伦斯（Jennifer Lawrence）、A$AP Rocky、艾玛·张伯伦（Emma Chamberlain）、我不知道，亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler），随便什么人。五个你真正钦佩其衣着的人。打开 Pinterest。打开任何平台。
Make a PowerPoint presentation. Put a bunch of their outfits that you love on that PowerPoint slide. What are the core, like, words or themes that define all of those pieces or all of those outfits? Bold, sleek, branded, colorful, maximalist, chaotic, athletic, simple. Like, whatever it is, find the connecting words. Choose two of those words. and then identify the word that would best describe your personality, or how you want to be seen, or how you see yourself.
做一个 PowerPoint 演示文稿。把一堆你喜欢的他们的服装放在那个 PowerPoint 幻灯片上。定义所有这些单品或所有这些服装的核心词汇或主题是什么？大胆、流畅、带有品牌标志、色彩丰富、极繁主义、混乱、运动风、简约？不管是什么，找出连接词。选择其中的两个词。然后找出最能描述你的性格、或者你想如何被看待、或者你如何看待自己的词。
So like dreamer, mystic, intellectual, adventurer, nurturer, entrepreneur, what word, if you could choose, just one, just one word, sits at like the center of your identity as your archetype. Then you put it all together. The effortless, but bold entrepreneur. The sleek, flowy mystic, the smart, colorful intellectual. the unassuming, accessorized creative. This sounds so cliche. It sounds so silly.
所以像梦想家、神秘主义者、知识分子、冒险家、滋养者、企业家，哪个词，如果你能选择的话，只有一个，仅仅一个词，作为你的原型处于你身份的核心。然后你把它们组合在一起。毫不费力却又大胆的企业家。流畅飘逸的神秘主义者，精明多彩的知识分子。朴实无华、富有配饰的创意人士。这听起来太陈词滥调了。听起来太傻了。
I know, but you have no idea how helpful this is mentally, how much of an identity shortcut this has been for me in realizing my personal style, especially in a trend-heavy society. If I find myself wanting to buy something, especially an impulse purchase, especially if it's a micro-trend, I go back to my archetype and I basically ask, is this something like a smart, playful scholar
我知道，但你不知道这在心理上有多么有用，这在认识我的个人风格方面为我提供了一条多么巨大的身份捷径，尤其是在一个充斥着潮流的社会里。如果我发现自己想买东西，尤其是冲动消费，尤其是微趋势，我会回到我的原型，基本上问自己，这是否是像一个智能、好玩的学者
would wear? That's my archetype, by the way. That feels very private to share, but smart playful scholar. That's how I make all my clothing choices. And it really, really helps. If it doesn't match that and if that's how I want to be seen, and obviously you could have a couple if you want, but I'm not going to wear it. Like, I'm not going to wear something that like a maximalist entrepreneur would wear because I'm not a maximalist entrepreneur. I'm not going to wear something that like a bold, I don't know, what's some of the words? Like a, I was going to say simple scientists, but that's kind of rude. But, you know, like all these other archetypes, they're wonderful and I'm sure they all dress
会穿的衣服？顺便说一句，这就是我的原型。分享这个感觉非常隐私，但智能好玩学者。这就是我做出所有服装选择的方式。它真的、真的很有帮助。如果不符合那个标准，如果那就是我想被看待的方式，显然如果你愿意的话你可以有几个，但我不会穿它。就像，我不会穿极繁主义企业家会穿的衣服，因为我不是极繁主义企业家。我不会穿那种大胆的衣服，我不知道，有些什么词？比如，我本来想说简单的科学家，但那样有点粗鲁。但是，你知道，就像所有这些其他的原型一样，它们很棒，而且我确信他们都穿得
well, but they're not me. And so it stops me from, this is so cliche, but like trying to be something that I'm not, trying to be like, trying to dress a way that like I'm just never going to enjoy. I would also say kind of as part of this as well, pick a uniform. Similar to that kind of historical analysis of past items we were talking about, what is the staple outfit you wear almost every day? Like blue jeans, blazer, sneaker, mini skirt, tight top boots, suit pant, cool shoe, tote bag. Like, what is your uniform?
很好，但那不是我。所以这阻止了我，这太陈词滥调了，就像试图成为我不是的人，试图穿一种我永远都不会喜欢的衣服。我还要说，作为其中的一部分，选择一套制服。类似于我们之前讨论过的对过去单品的历史分析，你几乎每天都穿的经典服装是什么？比如蓝色牛仔裤、西装外套、运动鞋、迷你裙、紧身上衣靴子、西装裤、酷鞋、手提包。比如，你的制服是什么？
When in doubt, just change one item from your uniform every day. You know, I didn't come up with that advice. I heard somebody else speak about it. But again, it stops you from buying pieces that you have nothing to wear with. Because if they wouldn't go with the uniform, chances are like they aren't going to go with the other things that you own either. And it keeps everything kind of centered around what you know you already lean towards. Finally, I feel like this is such an underrated tip.
拿不准主意时，每天只换掉制服中的一件单品。你知道，这个建议不是我想出来的。我听别人说过。但同样，这可以防止你购买那些找不到任何衣服与之搭配的单品。因为如果它们不配制服，那么它们也很有可能不配你拥有的其他东西。而且它让一切都围绕着你已知自己偏向的风格展开。最后，我觉得这是一个被严重低估的技巧。
But pay attention to what you are drawn to outside of clothing and fashion. if you are committed to finding your personal style. Often, things that are seemingly unrelated to fashion are the most inspiring things because of the feelings they evoke. And I'm saying that as somebody who doesn't understand fashion at all. I've just been told, but it might be like a certain colour or like a mood or your favourite film or an album cover or a music video or like even nature. The one I always think of as like the Mamma Mia movie.
但是，如果你致力于寻找自己的个人风格，请关注服装和时尚之外你所被吸引的事物。通常，看似与时尚无关的事物是最具启发性的，因为它们唤起了某种感觉。我是以一个根本不懂时尚的人的身份这么说的。我只是听说的，但它可能是一种特定的颜色、或一种情绪、或你最喜欢的电影、或专辑封面、或音乐录影带、甚至大自然。我总是想到的是像《妈妈咪呀》这部电影。
How many people dress the way they do because of the Mamma Mia movie? Or Abba. Look at tons of different things. Look at all these different influences and allow that to inspire you. Because I think fast fashion can make our pool of inspiration so narrow. You've got to try your best to broaden this in whatever way you can by looking elsewhere. So that I don't know if this is an ambition. Maybe you're happy to look like everybody else.
有多少人因为《妈妈咪呀》这部电影而这样穿衣打扮？或者阿巴乐队。看看各种不同的东西。看看所有这些不同的影响，并以此来激发你的灵感。因为我认为快时尚会让我们的灵感源泉变得如此狭窄。你必须尽你所能，通过在别处寻找来尽可能拓宽这一范围。这样我就不知道这是否是一个抱负。也许你很高兴看起来和别人一样。
And honestly, power to you. But if that's not your ambition, this is the way to prevent that from happening. seek inspiration from beyond what is the easiest thing to sell you and what is the easiest thing to sell you because everybody likes it because it is trending also vinted deep hop shops charity shops do that as much as possible
说实话，权力属于你。但如果那不是你的抱负，这就是防止这种情况发生的方法。从最容易卖给你的东西之外寻找灵感，而且因为每个人都喜欢它因为它正在流行，所以最容易卖给你，还有 vinted、depop 商店、慈善商店，尽可能多地这样做。
this has nothing to do with psychology I just think the most stylish people I know know how to hunt for their clothes and they know how to find yeah really basic things but versions that very few people have like the white t-shirt My friend found like this crazy white t-shirt from like the 70s the other day on Vinted for like five pounds.
这与心理学完全无关，我只是认为我认识的最时髦的人懂得如何为自己的衣服寻宝，他们知道如何寻找，是的，非常基础的东西，但却是极少数人拥有的版本，比如白大捧。我的朋友前几天在 Vinted 上以五英镑左右的价格买到了一件来自 70 年代的疯狂白 T 恤。
Like that's incredible. Nobody else has that white t-shirt. Like it's about taking, yeah, those fundamental things and just making it more fun and enjoyable. Because I think that's what fashion should really be about. Our final golden rule for personal style is about impulse shopping. And I have to sneak this one in here because it is so important. I used to have a huge problem with impulse shopping. I think a real reason why our personal style gets diluted and gets mashed up and like ripped apart is because we just like because of emotional regulation in a way.
这太不可思议了。没有其他人有那件白 T 恤。这就像是获取，是的，那些基础的东西，然后让它变得更有趣、更愉快。因为我认为这才是时尚真正应该关注的。我们关于个人风格的最后一条黄金法则与冲动购物有关。我不得不把这条塞进来，因为它太重要了。我曾经有严重的冲动购物问题。我认为我们的个人风格被稀释、被打碎并被撕裂的一个真正原因是因为我们只是，在某种程度上是为了调节情绪。
Like this is something that I found. I would just shop when I felt sad or lonely and I wasn't being intentional with the pieces I was buying. so I would just have all this like crap and none of it went together and I felt I'd feel like guilty one week and then I'd feel the emotions come back and I'd overspend the next week then I'd feel guilty wait 72 hours 48, 72 hours before you buy anything you want to buy unless it is something that you literally could not live without like if you genuinely are on holiday and you've run out of underwear you can obviously break the 48 hour rule but nobody needs like another pair of, like your fourth pair of blue jeans, like instantly as soon as you're seeing them.
就像我发现的这一点。我会在感到悲伤或孤独时购物，而且我在买东西时并不是出于刻意。所以我就会买一堆垃圾，没有一件是搭调的，我一个星期会感到内疚，然后情绪卷土重来，下一个星期又过度消费，然后感到内疚。在你想要买任何东西之前，等待 72 小时、48、72 小时，除非它是那种你简直无法没有它的东西，比如如果你真的在度假，内衣穿完了，你显然可以打破 48 小时规则，但没有人需要像另一双，比如你的第四条蓝色牛仔裤那样，一看到就马上买。
And even if you do, even if, for example, you'd like need a skirt or you need like a suit jacket for like an upcoming event, if that is the case, make it your mission then to find the best version of that at the price point you can. Not just the first one you see. I think when it comes to personal style and the psychology behind personal style, yes, it is about understanding your personality and yes, it is about understanding how style and identity contribute to each other and grow hand in hand. I also think then there's this second element where you understand it and then you put it into practice. And if this is a priority for you and if you want to look, if you want to have like that brand, if you want to have that real identifiable Steve Jobs-esque kind of look, like people know that those are the clothes you wear,
即使你这样做，即使，举个例子，你需要一条裙子或者你需要一件西装外套来参加即将到来的活动，如果是这样的话，那么你的任务就是以你能承受的价格点找到它的最佳版本。而不仅仅是你看到的第一个。我认为当谈到个人风格以及个人风格背后的心理学时，是的，它是关于理解你的个性，是的，它是关于理解风格和身份如何相互促进并齐头并进。我也认为这里有第二个要素，你理解了它，然后你将其实际付诸实践。如果这是你的首选，如果你想看起来，如果你想拥有那种品牌，如果你想拥有那种真正可辨识的史蒂夫·乔布斯式的造型，就像人们知道那些就是你穿的衣服，
you've got to be intentional, you've got to be focused on what it is that you actually like and in many ways you have to actually buy less. All of those tips that I kept coming back to for, that weren't just buying the tips from like stylists and I don't even know the word. So obviously I'm not as clued in as they would be
你必须是有意的，你必须专注于你真正喜欢的东西，在许多方面你实际上必须买得少一些。我不断提到的所有那些建议，不仅仅是来自造型师的购买建议，我甚至不知道那个词。所以很明显我没有他们那么了解
but like fashion editors and fashion journalists, that's the word. They're all about consuming less actually. And I think that's this real thing. The thing that's making us have less personal style is this just like periodic blasting of the trend of the season. And this like periodic, this periodic like, I don't know, I don't want to say archetype. But yeah, like archetype like this year, this month we're fairy corn, next month we're cottage corn, then we're like grunge corn and all these things. and all of that is just asking you to buy more and to keep these big fast fashion businesses in business. And it's not doing great things for your personal style.
但是像时尚编辑和时尚记者，就是这个词。其实它们都关乎减少消费。我认为这是一个真正的问题。导致我们个人风格变少的事情，就是这种对当季潮流的周期性狂轰滥炸。以及这种周期性的，这种周期性的，我不知道，我不想说原型。但是，是的，就像原型一样，今年这个月我们是精灵风，下个月我们是乡村风，然后我们是垃圾摇滚风，所有这些东西。所有这些都只是要求你买更多，并让这些大型快时尚企业继续维持下去。这对你的个人风格没有太大好处。
It's obviously not doing great things for the planet either. If you want to break out of that, you've got to kind of look away from trends. You've got to consume more slowly and more intentionally. And you've got to focus on like the real soul of your clothes and how that is like a direct peek into your personality. this is going to sound so woo-woo. Maybe I've gone too far here. Maybe it is time to end this episode. But like this just came to my mind.
显然这对地球也没有什么大好处。如果你想摆脱这种困境，你必须把视线从潮流中移开。你必须更慢、更有意识地消费。你必须专注于衣服真正的灵魂，以及这如何成为窥探你个性的直接窗口。这听起来太玄乎了。也许我在这里走得太远了。也许是时候结束这一集了。但这个想法刚刚闯入我的脑海。
Honestly, maybe that's the assessment you have to do. Before you buy anything, you have to genuinely look at this item and be like, does this say something about me? Like could somebody say, could somebody tell you something about the person I am from this item and why I'm choosing to buy it? Bit wacky. I don't know. You can take that or leave that. But I think I'm going to start doing that.
说实话，也许这就是你必须做的评估。在买任何东西之前，你必须真正地看着这件单品，然后想：这说明了关于我的一些事情吗？就像有人能，有人能从这件单品以及我为什么选择买它看出关于我是什么样的人的一些事情吗？有点古怪。我不知道。你可以接受或拒绝。但我认为我将开始这样做。
I think that is a great way to make more intentional purchases. So thank you for listening. If you have made it this far, our question of the day, if you are listening on Spotify, what is your uniform slash what is the item of clothing that you have had the longest and why? I will go first. It is a Brandy Melville, carkey singlet that I bought in 2013. And I actually don't own it anymore. I only recently threw it out.
我认为这是进行更有意识消费的好方法。所以感谢大家的收听。如果你坚持听到了最后，我们今日的问题是：如果你在使用 Spotify 收听，你的“制服”是什么？换句话说，你拥有的时间最长的衣物是什么，为什么？我先来。是一件我 2013 年买的 Brandy Melville 卡其色背心。其实我早就没有它了。我直到最近才把它扔掉。
And that sinklet has not been wearable outside slash didn't even fit for years, but it was this weird thing where I was like really holding onto it tight and I couldn't let it go. So what is your version of the Brandy Melville-Carky singlet? I want to know, leave a comment. Thank you as always to our lovely, wonderful researcher Libby Colbert. She really did some amazing research for this episode, so we appreciate her so much. make sure as well that if you are listening and you're in the US or Canada, you give us a watch
而且那件背心已经好几年没法穿出门了，甚至根本穿不下了，但它就是那种很奇怪的东西，我当时紧紧抓着它不放，就是舍不得扔。所以，你版本的 Brandy Melville 卡其色背心是什么？我想知道，快来留言吧。一如既往地感谢我们可爱、出色的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）。她真的为这期节目做了非常棒的研究，我们超级感激她。另外请确保，如果你正在收听，并且身在美国或加拿大，记得去观看我们的节目
on Netflix, that is correct, video episodes of the podcast are now on Netflix and we would really appreciate it if you are in those two countries, checking it out and telling us what you think. You can also follow us on Substack if you want the episode transcript for this episode, including links to any of the studies, but until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through
在 Netflix 上，没错，播客的视频节目现在已经在 Netflix 上线了。如果你身处这两个国家，我们非常希望你能去看一看，并告诉我们你的想法。如果你想要本期节目的文字稿（包括任何研究链接），也可以在 Substack 上关注我们。但今天就到这里，注意安全，保持善良，对温柔对待自己，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中的心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历
some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是 TWO%，可以在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和说意义重大。84 年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试着和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起，弄明白我们是如何熬过那些日子的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈 80 年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
84 年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这么做。在 iHeart 广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难成长》。在 2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same. same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
另外两个经历过同样事情的人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart 广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart 广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。